BRIAN: MANY IN THE MEDIA
IGNORING THIS STORY BUT WE ARE
NOT.
DAMNING DETAILS REAL ESTATE VEAL
HOW FAR ANDREW CUOMO’S SENIOR
AIDES REPORTEDLY WENT TO CONCEAL
THE NUMBER OF NURSING HOME
DEATHS DURING THE PANDEMIC.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTS
THAT CUOMO’S OFFICE STOPPED
HEALTH OFFICIALS FROM PLUSING
THE REAL NUMBER OF NURSING HOME
DATA FOR MONTHS.
MORE THAN A YEAR AGO OUR VERY
OWN JANICE DEAN LOST BOTH
IN-LAW’S.
BEFUDDLED AND OBVIOUSLY SADDENED
BUT KNEW WE NEEDED TO GET
ANSWERS.
AFTER COVID AND WENT BACK TO THE
NURSING HOME ONCE THEY WERE
POSITIVE FOR THIS KNOWING THEY
HAD OTHER OPTIONS.
IT WAS LIKE BURNISHING A
FURNACE.
PUTTING GASOLINE ON IT JANICE
DEAN JOINS US NOW.
JANICE, THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
FINDS DOCUMENTS THAT THE MARCH
DIRECTIVE THAT WAS REVERSED A
COUPLE OF MONTHS LATER WAS MORE
DAMAGING THAN ANYONE THOUGHT.
THEY DOWN PLAYED THE NUMBER OF
DEATHS.
HOW SIGNIFICANT IS THIS
ALLEGATION?
>> WELL, YOU HAVE TO ASK WHY DID
THEY DOWN PLAY THOSE NUMBERS FOR
SO LONG?
AND THIS IS EXTENSIVE.
EXTENT THAT THEY WENT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS WAS NOT
UNCOVERED, RIGHT?
AND HE WOULD GO ON THESE
INTERVIEWS ON TELEVISION WHEN
THEY WOULD FINALLY ASK HIM THE
QUESTION ABOUT THE NURSING
HOMES, HE WOULD GIVE FALSE
INFORMATION AND HE KNEW ALL
ALONG HE WAS HIGHING.
SO WHY DID HE AND HIS TOP AIDES,
INCLUDING MELISSA DER ROSA, GO
TO SUCH GREAT LENGTHS TO MAKE
SURE THAT NO ONE WOULD FIND OUT
THE REAL TOTAL OF THE DEATHS?
I THINK IT’S BECAUSE IT’S
CRIMINAL AND HE HAD A BOOK TO
SELL, A $4 MILLION BOOK.
BRIAN: SO, JUST FOR EVERYONE TO
UNDERSTAND, BECAUSE SOME OTHER
STATES DID THE SAME THING, MARCH
INITIAL DIRECTIVE INSTRUCTING
NURSING HOMES TO ACCEPT THEIR
PATIENTS BACK IN WHO WERE
POSITIVE FOR THE VIRUS INSTEAD
OF STAYING OUT OF THE HOSPITAL
OR STAYING OUT OF THE WAY OR
GOING TO THE SHIP.
IN MAY HE REALIZED THAT’S A
PROBLEM, APPARENTLY, AND HE
REVERSED THAT HE SAID 6,000
PEOPLE LOST THEIR LIVES.
THE NUMBER WAS 15,000.
THAT WAS A DEMOCRATIC ATTORNEY
GENERAL THAT FOUND OUT THAT.
WE’RE FINDING OUT NOW THAT HE
KNEW THE TOTAL ALL ALONG, NEVER
ANSWERED QUESTIONS AT HIS DAILY
PRESS CONFERENCES, EITHER.
JANICE: LIED, EVERY SINGLE TIME.
IF THIS IS NOT OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE, I DON’T KNOW WHAT IS,
BRIAN.
I FEEL LIKE HIM, THE GOVERNOR,
AND THE PEOPLE AROUND HIM THAT
KNEW THIS AND TRIED TO COVER IT
UP, THEY NEED TO GO TO JAIL I
DON’T THINK THAT’S EVER GOING TO
HAPPEN.
I DO WANT JUSTICE TO HAPPEN ON
BEHALF OF THE 15,000 DEAD FAMILY
MEMBERS.
BRIAN: SO COMMISSIONER HOWARD
ZUCKER I KNOW YOU WORK FOR THE
GOVERNOR BUT WHAT DO YOU STAND
FOR.
HE WAS BASICALLY TOLD KEEP YOUR
MOUTH SHUT.
HE IS THE NEW YORK STATE HEALTH
OFFICIAL.
THEY SAID DON’T RELEASE THIS
DEATH TOLL AND HE DIDN’T.
AND WHEN HE IS ASKED ABOUT IT,
HE SKIRTS IT.
HERE IS WHAT CUOMO’S ATTORNEY
SAYS, THE WHOLE BROUHAHA HERE IS
OVERBLOWN TO THE POINT WHERE
THERE ARE CYNICAL SUGGESTIONS
FOR THE PLAIN AND SIMPLE TRUTH
THAT THE CHAMBER ONLY WANTED TO
RELEASE ACCURATE INFORMATION
THEY BELIEVED WAS TOTALLY
UNASSAILABLE.
THAT DOESN’T PASS THE LAUGH OR
SMELL TEST.
JANICE: TO THE DEATHS OF OVER
15,000 ELDERLY IS A BROUHAHA?
THAT’S WHAT THE LAWYER HAS TO
SAY?
I THINK OUR FAMILIES DESERVE
JUSTICE AND I HOPE IT HAPPENS
SOON.
OUR LAWMAKERS IN ALBANY NEED TO
DO SOMETHING.
THIS WHITE WASH OF AN
IMPEACHMENT IS RIDICULOUS.
GO IN THERE TODAY AND GET IT
DONE.
THERE ARE AT LEAST FOUR
INVESTIGATIONS INTO THIS
GOVERNOR.
HOW MUCH MORE DO YOU NEED TO GET
HIM OUT?
BRIAN: JANICE, ON A SIDE NOTE,
HE WAS ASKED ABOUT HIS ACCUSERS
THIS WEEK.
HE BASICALLY SAYS THEY ARE
VENAL, THEY ARE PUBLICITY HOUNDS
AND THEY ARE LIARS.
AND THEN HE SAID YEAH, I TOUCHED
SOME PEOPLE BUT NEVER
INAPPROPRIATELY.
HOW THE HECK HE STILL HAS A JOB
OR DEMOCRAT STAND FOR THE ME TOO
MOVEMENT I WILL NEVER
UNDERSTAND.
I DON’T GET IT BUT HE SEEMS TO
BE SELLING OUT TO THE LEFT SO
THEY DON’T TURN ON HIM AND FORCE
HIM OUT.
AND THAT’S WHY WE ARE ALL
GETTING TAX INCREASES AND
EVERYTHING THAT WE ARE SEEING
RIGHT NOW.
JANICE DEAN, THANKS SO MUCH.
DON’T GIVE UP.